foreign
[Music]
good morning everyone welcome to today's
session of build an AI Ops platform at
Enterprise scale with Google cloud my
name is Sharon I'm a product manager
here at Google I'm happy to be joined on
stage today with Bruno who's a principal
architect at Google as well as Michael
who is a SAS security engineer at Uber
for 8 A.M we appreciate that thank you
thank you
um so to in today's session we'll cover
a lot we'll talk a little bit about what
is AI Ops we'll talk about
infrastructure intelligence we'll give a
customer example of how they were able
to build a custom AI app solution then
we'll talk about how you can get started
really quickly with AI Ops with active
assist Michael from Uber will then join
us to talk about his experience there
and then we'll give a little hint at
what's to come on Google Cloud
and so that let's get started with what
is AI Ops
so let's first start with a problem that
I think everyone in this room should be
familiar with where you have an outage
and you have to figure out what went
wrong did something change recently
what's the root cause of this problem
there's a lot of finger pointing and War
rooms um trying to solve this issue and
so that brings us to AI Ops which is a
term coined by Gartner that refers to
the application of artificial
intelligence to automate processes and
discover problems so that outages and
issues that we just discussed can be
prevented in the future
and so our customers know that you know
Google has some of the largest data
centers and infrastructure in the world
and we've published books on this like
the SRE book and customers want to know
how we do it so I wanted to quickly
touch upon Google's approach to
intelligent operations
uh we can think of it as divided into
kind of four sections uh the first is
that whatever system or platform that
you build must be able to see so it
should have basic monitoring and
observability capabilities
um into the data then it must be able to
think it should be able to analyze the
data produce insights then do actually
take action on those insights through
root cause analysis provide
recommendations and then finally care
continuously learn based off user
activity
and continuously improve the system as
well as the data with the ultimate goal
of being what we call self-healing
um and so with those four pillars in
mind I'll invite Bruno up to the stage
to talk a little bit more about
infrastructure intelligence
thank you Sharon
and thanks folks for joining us early in
the morning on this uh very interesting
topic for me so I'm a principal
architect as mentioned before so and I
work in the healthcare Life Sciences
space and one of the things we were
trying to do with my customer Johnson
Johnson they were looking to automate
their operations
across the board including some of the
things we talk about so I'm going to
talk a little bit about the platform
itself and then I'm going to get into a
little bit more about the use case and
the architecture and then obviously
we'll be opening up to the Uber story
and talking and having some q a after
that
so
so same problem that Sharon mentioned
right they had a simple problem quote
unquote right how do we triage an
application outage
who you know who's to blame you know it
always comes down to those kind of silly
things like where is
um uh is it because of a network outage
did it uh database change that affected
a bunch of other systems do we need to
bring in Google Oracle all these
different partners right having all
these War Room sessions right it's a
very very difficult problem to uh to try
to solve and one of the most important
things you need to do is to figure out
you know again based on those four
principles that Google has like how do
we get our arms around the data what's
the data that we need for observability
without the good data without the good
information we're not going to be able
to really triage the problem properly
and it's not an easy task because you're
working with different silos different
systems
Etc
the other thing that's really important
and this is common for all customers is
how do these pieces of infrastructure
interrelate to each other right so for
example if I was to change a version of
a database it could affect the front-end
web applications it could FedEx affect
some back end systems some other systems
we're not aware of a network change can
obviously have a trick a ripple effect
across multiple multiple systems so
being able to map what systems are
affected by which by each other and what
the relationships are is also key so
data and the relationships between the
systems
now one of the pieces that you really
need to take time we did this with with
jnj but in general I think all customers
should look at it this way is what are
the pieces of of log data and
infrastructure data that we need
to pull in right so I talked a little
bit about that before and it's not
everything it's not so obvious I guess
if you look at some of the main things
we have there like yeah machine logs
application logs that makes sense right
Network logs performance logs auditing
and security logs but then you want to
look at things like
um synthetic actions maybe we want to
simulate a strain on the system before
we release that new you know network
configuration we may want to also pull
in human sentiment and this is where
some of the Google
benefits kind of shine compared to other
Solutions because you could say Hey you
know I could take data from anywhere and
throw it into any solution start to do
this in that Analytics
we with bigquery we have the ability to
pull in external data sets very easily
we maintain that Google maintains that
for you so think about for example if
um
there's a an incident like we have the
Hurricanes we have earthquakes in the
area things like that that could affect
the data center for Johnson Johnson or
for whatever customer right so that
weather data is actually important for
us to plan outages or hopefully plan
upgrades without outages I should say
and then things like human sentiment
analysis so yeah how does human session
analysis kind of fit into this think
about call center information where
you're getting a lot of customers
calling in and saying performance on
applications bad or it keeps crashing
get two of those tickets five of those
tickets 10 of those tickets we have an
issue right that should be automated we
shouldn't we shouldn't know about the
issue after the customer is already
suffering right so pulling in that
information is really important and we
have partner adapters and connectors to
things like Twitter
Facebook so people don't necessarily
call the data center there's they're
just like oh my God Bruno's application
was really awful today right whatever it
is right they're not going to
necessarily call bruno.com
by the way I don't have that site yet
but maybe I'll buy it uh to find out
what's going on
and all that kind of falls into kind of
getting to True root cause analysis
feeding in all those aspects of data to
try to see where is you know the most
you know support tickets coming from
Plus network plus this okay now I have a
root cause analysis because it seems to
be a network issue based on these
tickets based on these uh calls that
we're getting in
so let's talk a little bit about
a use case where we took this platform
and we actually partnered with HCL
they're one of the Premier sponsors here
today if you want to meet with them
later I can introduce you and they
talked about
um with the customer with ourselves uh
kind of an evaluation like what's the
best approach to automating and doing
some AI Ops
and uh so the need was so J J has an
effort going on to reduce their spend
and to reduce their operation costs by
50 million over the next few years
um they looked at Google as a piece of
this to try to automate some of their
service tickets through servicenow and
some other pieces
what they did was a proof of concept and
wanted to understand what kind of why
Google would be good at this they found
the ease of bigquery basically within a
month we were pulling in servicenow
tickets through bigquery through looker
having an analytics platform so we
already had a dashboard across a bunch
of different systems for them that they
didn't see before as well as starting to
triage some of their tickets so they
were like this is quick this is easy
let's continue on with this as well the
other key piece and this is tough with
every company is having a good sponsor
so we were lucky at J J that we had the
head of Ops we had this initiative and
this is like you guys are going to do
this no network team you're going to
give them the data you know because the
first thing they're like oh we do this
already networking we got it down we're
fine it's like yeah but do you realize
that a security change or database
change could be affecting your network
and vice versa right that
interrelationship piece is the hard part
so having a good sponsor and also
proving it out helped start to break
down the side us
and then you know
what was the customer actually able to
do in this case so they were shooting
for 50 million they were super
successful 200 million savings across
the board over the first couple of years
uh Google was 3.2 million of that
um so
the only application we did I think was
servicenow it was a very basic
application and they already were
achieving 3.2 million so this year we're
hoping we're pulling in network logs
Linux logs all these other types of you
know device logs are coming into this
environment now and so hopefully we'll
improve the system
even more
so just to talk a little bit about the
approach that we took there and this is
a model that will probably would follow
most customers again depends on your
your partner or yourselves so first
propose an architecture that works right
so what are the data criteria what is
the service level criteria what is it
you're trying to really achieve kind of
what's the best bang for the buck uh for
the bucket first and then kind of what's
the future growth and then basically
having the landing Zone and
infrastructure to test it out okay it's
very easy to believe it or not a proof
of concept with this environment so you
could just pull in a bunch of logs get
some looker dashboards we have some
pre-built ones that already do some of
these kind of what-if scenarios and
analytics that work really well
having that whole platform is important
then the first piece is okay let's give
some dashboard and observability to
people kind of prove ourselves out and
that was very successful
um as I mentioned already
and then what we started to do is start
to put the AI in there so again with
bigquery and these platforms we have
integration to AI so being able to do
what we call the traffic cop analysis so
think of 15 different servicenow tickets
got opened about some kind of
performance issue but they're all
related around I'll keep picking on
networking I hope there's not Network
folks out here that I'm using networking
as an example but it's an easy one to
use like they're all kind of pointing to
the network so we should be able to kind
of learn from that and the next time a
ticket comes in not have to wait for 15
of them we kind of can group them
together know that there's a network
issue so we already started doing that
with some pretty basic models the next
piece that we're looking to do
is and we're actually starting to build
out there is how do we take this
platform improve upon it and do things
like
um the magical self-healing at some
point right right now we're doing some
Predictive Analytics so let's see some
what-if scenarios Google does the same
thing when they're about to implement a
network change they actually have what
if uh environment that actually tests
things out before they push it out same
kind of things there and then we also
started talking to the security folks so
this started opening the doors to
everyone uh in the environment so the
security team's like this is really cool
I need to know more information about my
Audits and and what what's happening in
the environment you guys can give us a
more full picture of of devices that are
logging on from the device logs Etc
and one of the pieces they're looking to
do is potentially put Chronicle in there
because basically you have the landing
Zone already you've got the feeds
Chronicle concern through all that and
start to detect cyber threats
um I chart
architecture it'll be in the slides for
you uh later for for next to download
but this is an example of the platform
architecture uh pieces of which are
implemented today now Jane Jack
um so you can see from left to right
you're collecting different data points
I mentioned that I mentioned the ability
with bigquery to leverage uh a lot of
public data sources as well as internal
data sources as well as servicenow as
well as they're looking at teams for
pulling in chat so people are chatting
there's some issue with something going
on they can pull that in as well then
the transformation piece obviously
cleaning up the data deduping things
like that
then analyzing it so this is where the
strength of bigquery with looker comes
in right one once it's in bigquery we
can just go at it and we can actually
add some machine learning which we did
so in this case we've got some NLP and
we also have some custom machine models
that they built to do some of the
traffic cop analysis they're putting in
some Predictive Analytics next
and then as I mentioned looker is the
the visualization of everything that's
going on
the next piece they're also looking to
do is well this is great for there this
is actually all for their on-prem
infrastructure in their data centers
they're like we got to extend this to
the other clouds next so this is where
active assist comes in we're going to
talk about that later
um we're like well for Google we kind of
got a you know a leg up because we can
start feeding in the automated AI pieces
from Google that already start to detect
these things like Network performance
like security uh monitoring where maybe
this person can have all the security
across all these different things uh
compute monitoring so those kinds of
things so we're already feeding not just
logs from Google we can actually start
pulling in from the AI recommenders and
the active assist pieces as well
so this is just kind of a a brief
summary slide of what I mentioned so
really what the platform did for Jay and
Jane for customers in general is kind of
bottom up break the silos I think that's
really important it's really cool to see
after about a year on this project that
teams are coming to us I never thought
the security risk management team would
come to this team and say yeah we'll
give you more data and we'd like to work
with they're always like stay away from
us at security right that kind of now
they're like yeah maybe we should be
working together they really see I think
people see Google as a leader and kind
of modeling what we do in our data
centers to support their own data
centers again I talked about the savings
and the overachievement so you can see
some real value and some real goals
okay with that I'm going to pass it uh
back to Sharon and uh we'll be talking
to you later
thanks
great thanks Bruno
um so we just talked about how one
customer was able to build you know a
comprehensive custom AI op solution but
what if you were short on time as well
as resources this is a great way where
active assist is already available to do
today on your gcp projects and it's
really easy to to integrate into any
custom AI app solution as well as IT
addresses some of the use cases for AI
Ops such as advanced business insights
predictive capacity management and
finding the needle in the haystack
so activeassists have at insights and
recommendations that help you optimize
your Cloud across a variety of value
pillars whether it's you want to
optimize your cost improve your
reliability improve your performance Etc
so like I said they are available to you
today on your Google Cloud projects you
can see them on the UI API CLI or you
can export them to a bigquery data set
and so with that I'll invite Michael
onto this stage who will talk a little
bit about how Uber was able to integrate
with active assist in their own
intelligent automation solution
awesome thanks so much uh hi folks I'm
Michael I'm a security engineer at Uber
so I'm gonna talk about a few use cases
that are first and foremost
driven by security but also by some
other uh optimization requirements so
first uh a bit about our journey first
how did we get to active assist in the
first place so we um as a company we
started using Google Cloud around 2017
or so back then when we tried to do
optimizations on our infrastructure
pretty much as Bruno was saying earlier
right a lot of manual labor so we would
need to look at logs create the logs
into using bigquery and then trying to
do the optimizations manually
so um you know one example is looking
for inactive resources that we want to
remove from a security perspective right
we want to reduce the attack surface we
want to remove unused resources for that
would query the logs right look at audit
logs now if I'm going to try to look at
audit logs for the past 30 days 90 days
it's a bit of a hassle especially
because you need to filter out a lot of
the activities right there's the kind of
Observer affecting the observation
effect there so I need to filter out
myself looking at the project there's
other projects in gcp that can be using
service accounts looking into your
project so you need to filter out that
as well right so a bit of uh
significant work when we look at these
logs just to understand the activity on
a particular project
so around 2020 we started using active
assist for
as I mentioned for first and foremost
Security benefits but also quickly we
discovered that there's also cost
benefits and even sustainability
benefits so with that let's go to the
first example
so let's dive a bit deeper into this use
case of inactive projects on gcp now
organizations such as Uber has thousands
about two to three thousand projects at
any given day in gcp so quite a quite a
significant scale we cannot even hope to
manually keep track of projects usage
activity inactivity so let's take a look
at the left side here there's um four
different states that we are interested
in when we look at a project right a
project can have an owner an active
owner someone in the organization or
maybe a Google group
or maybe this owner left the
organization or moved to a different
team and the project no longer has an
active owner so this is built from a
security perspective right also from
maintenance perspective you want to have
someone that is in charge of a project
so either orphaned no owner or a project
is own now on the upper side here we can
also look at activity either a project
is currently active it has resources
that are running or maybe it has
resources but they're not really used so
inactive
so on the left upper side this is where
we want to be we want to have an active
owner to a project and we want to have
activity in this project
if we go down we can see that if a
project is used but it's over front well
then we need to find another owner
on the upper right quadrant right we can
see a project is uh unused and we have
an owner so we can talk to this owner
and say hey looks like this project is
not being used take a look right maybe
you want to delete this project delete
the resources and the project itself
so for that we built automation on top
of active assist I mentioned first we're
looking into the logs it was a bit of a
hassle then we switch to activities as a
simple API call to activeassist and we
get the understanding of whether the
project is actually used or not also we
get the CO2 emissions from this project
and simple additional call to a cost API
we got the cost that this project
consumes
so on the right side you can see this is
an example of a jira ticket that we
create
so we're signing to the project owner we
say hey take a look at this project you
have
looks like unused resources in this
project the project driven generates so
and so carbon emissions the cost is so
and so so we motivate the owner to get
rid of unused resources removing this
project again reduces the attack surface
benefit to security benefit to reduction
of cost and sustainability
and then finally in the red quadrant
down right side if a project is not used
and it is orphaned generally we can just
get rid of this project ourselves now we
need to do it carefully right because
what if someone uses a project once in a
long time right once in a while
um and it so happens that the project is
not used it's not owned so generally we
start by blocking permission to the
project we stop the resources before we
delete it so do a bit of a scream test
before we actually delete ourselves
now how did we build this
so on the right side you can see the
architecture it's entirely on gcp using
gcp Services we have a cloud scheduler
every now and then triggers through pops
up worker Cloud functions the cloud
functions communicate with active assist
query active assist for project activity
and query billing API for the project
cost then we store this results in
firestore
and through another Pub sub message we
talked to jira or servicenow or slack
and reach out to the project owner
saying hey take a look at this project
looks like it's not being active it's
not a complex architecture right
encourage everyone to you know to take a
look and maybe you can build it or see
yourself I'm sure you can do those
yourselves
and immediately reduce the cost
and the attack surface so quite
beneficial
okay let's move to the next example
again we're still in the security world
right uh IAM recommendations so we know
that in gcp we assign roles
to uh project owners to users now these
roles are often over privileged right it
used to be the case that everyone would
just ask for the owner role or an editor
role this is not what we want to do
right we want to have least privilege so
how do we tackle this
so again we look at activities so this
time we look at IEM recommendations
and if we see that there is a
recommendation of reducing the roles
reducing the permissions we again use in
our case Jiro service now tickets to
talk to the owner and recommend reducing
these privileges these permissions so
it's completely automated right the user
pretty much has to just click on accept
recommendation and the role the the
unnecessary roles get removed so you can
see on the right hand side it's a block
diagram of the architecture
uh manager it's just a fancy word for a
cloud function that runs a bit of a
logic talks to IEM recommender inactive
assist
then we decide to take an action based
on the recommendations
we attach risk scoring based on the over
privilegedness right of the findings
that we have and we decide to either
automatically remediate right so
essentially accepting accepting the
recommendation ourselves or create a
ticket and assign the ticket to a user
okay so again reducing the unnecessary
permissions reducing the attack surface
final uh example is a compute engine
recommender
so here we really want to
utilize our compute resources right we
often over provision compute resources
now before activities it was quite a
difficult job you would as Bruno was
saying you would have to look at the
logs coming from VM instances right we
need to understand how much CPU
utilization is being done maybe deploy
agents on these instances right today
it's much easier for us again just
another query pretty much to active
assist
understanding whether a VM has not been
utilized or is underutilized in terms of
CPU or memory maybe it has disks that
are attached but have never been used
so these recommendations allow us to
again generate tickets uh and in these
tickets we can ask hey maybe you know
de-attach remove these disk because it's
not needed save cost save on
sustainability as well
you can see on the right side this is
how the recommendations look like on
activist system really see active assist
as the managed ml or managed AI offering
for ourselves
so no more no more digging into the logs
right essentially as I mentioned just an
API query we see that we have unused
resources or we see that we need to
resize an instance and we can either
either accept this recommendation right
and and uh make the change ourselves or
ask an owner if it's a more delicate
change to uh do it on their part
reduction Tax Service cost and CO2
emissions
so with that I'll pass it on to Sharon
to summarize on AI Ops
just to quickly wrap up we talked about
how one customer was able to build a
custom AI op solution we talked about
how you can get quickly started on your
AI Ops Journey with active assist but I
just wanted to give a little quick hint
on what's to come so Google Cloud AI Ops
tools are coming in 2024 we know that
with the surge of AI in developer
productivity that we need to also
provide AI to help you set up monitoring
troubleshooting as well as mitigating
future issues so Google cloud is
investing in Native Solutions so that
you can have tools out of the box and
that's coming next year
and so with that thank you for attending
today's session I'd encourage you to
check out our other sessions if you
wanted to learn more about observability
tooling active assist green Ops and then
if you had further questions you can
also come to our devops booth in
innovators hive